barbershop cuts and cocktails battle of
the bands it just wrapped up and after a
long hard battle we have a winner velvet
chains now joining us now is paul edgar
from the barber shop and we have niles
and jason from the band
yes niels nielsen look at you guys look
like rock stars by the way you have that
look you have that presence about you
congratulations on winning the whole
thing man how was it ah that was great
thanks so much man thank you we enjoyed
it we loved playing there it was a blast
so paul what was the process like how
many bands did they have so we had 12
bands total it was a four week
competition three bands every week the
winner of each night would go on to the
final week in week five and then
battle it out for the grand prize with
the residency and the cash prize for
these guys so when the residency is
already underway right guys so that's
going to be starting kind of next month
okay it'll be a six-month contract so
the contest started back in the
beginning of june battle the bans we
announced our winner you get this new
residency how does that feel to have a
residency here in las vegas oh it feels
great i mean especially playing at the
barbershop you know with the roster of
musicians they're all top-notch so we
just we're super happy to be included in
that
how would you describe your sound if
someone's new to the band how would you
describe that we're definitely hard rock
we're influenced by hard rock from the
90s 2000s some people call it a little
bit dark rock but we're heavy yeah
how was it uh performing against these
other bands what'd you think of the
competition were you guys friendly or
bandwidth on stage like oh guys these
guys are awful
it's a small town and we're all friends
at the end of the day you know we all
wanted to win they wanted to win but at
the end of the day we're all friends and
it was a friendly competition but it was
it was good it was good one so you guys
are the pros and there's a lot of people
out there that want to sing and want to
try singing you guys do karaoke night as
well yeah tuesday night to do uh faded
karaoke it's a
bit different from a normal karaoke
where we have a band
around the kind of the person that comes
to sing so they gotta you know live out
the rockstar dream and you know perform
live on stage who do we have behind us
here who are the guys in
our rhythm guitar player you know a lot
of fun fact imagine dragons you know
imagine dragons right yeah they started
here in las vegas vegas band by winning
mix 94.1 battle the bands that launched
them to their to superstardom what's
next for you guys you win this
competition what do you see coming up
here in the future we have a bunch of
stuff coming out we're gonna play a
couple festivals around uh virginia
wisconsin we have a bunch of dates
coming up so yeah we're hopefully we're
on our way to yeah we've got a new
single drop in um right july july 8th
i love it what i love about this
interview is once you guys ever once you
become a household name they're to look
back on this interview like here's the
first interview that they did after they
won battle of bands and i get to be on
the interview thank you so much for
joining us i appreciate it thanks for
having us thanks paul thanks for coming
appreciate it thank you uh actually we
just don't have a couple more seconds
what are some other things that you guys
offer because there's events every night
right so like it is a live music venue
um but it's like a speakeasy so we have
like a fully functional barbers at the
front it's not just a name
so i'm going to have that there yep we
certainly can so yeah that's one of the
cool things it's like a very unique
experience like so it's awesome thank
you guys again so much for joining us
really appreciate it thank you so much
kendall over to you all right luke combs
hit the